endometriosis is a condition where
tissue similar to the lining in your
uterus grows in other areas of your body
if you are a woman your reproductive
system includes the vagina
uterus
fallopian tubes
and ovaries
during a normal menstrual cycle your
ovaries make chemicals called hormones
which signal the lining of your uterus
to thicken
the lining called the endometrium builds
up to prepare to receive a fertilized
egg
if the egg isn't fertilized
the uterus sheds the lining
through your vagina this monthly
bleeding is called your menstrual period
if you have endometriosis the lining
type tissue grows outside your uterus
for reasons that aren't clear
the misplaced tissue responds to the
hormones just like it would if it were
inside your uterus
the tissue continues to thicken then
sheds and bleeds with every menstrual
cycle however the blood and tissue that
are shed outside the uterus have no way
to leave your body
the trapped endometrial flow can
irritate the surrounding area causing
inflammation and pain
bands of scar tissue called adhesions
may form sticking one organ to another
or causing your fallopian tubes to close
this can affect your fertility which is
the ability to become pregnant
endometriosis can form endometriomas
also known as chocolate cysts these
cysts are fluid-filled sacs on your
ovaries that can affect fertility
endometriosis may also result in
abnormal bleeding
the most common sites for endometriosis
are the ovaries
fallopian tubes
the outside of your uterus
the supporting structures around your
uterus
and the lining of your pelvis called the
peritoneum
other sites include your bladder
rectum
and intestines
if you have endometriosis you may have
one or more of these
symptoms chronic usually worsening
central pelvic pain
pain before or during your period
pain during sex felt deep within your
pelvis
painful urination during your period
painful bowel movements during your
period
abnormal bleeding
diarrhea constipation or nausea
and difficulty getting pregnant called
infertility
your doctor may recommend treatment
options from the following categories
pain management medications such as
aspirin acetaminophen or non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs also known as
nsaids provide relief from pain
hormone therapy such as birth control
pills can prevent monthly endometrial
build up and bleeding
you may need a surgical procedure to
treat the tissue causing pain or
bleeding
examples of such procedures include
removal or destruction of endometrial
tissue
removal of adhesions and scar tissue
removal or drainage of cysts
removal or destruction of nerve fibers
that transmit pain
removal of your uterus
called a hysterectomy
or removal of your ovaries called an
oophorectomy